Gillan Andrew Dice Clay as children are
the most talented kids I've ever seen
there they're like virtuoso musicians
thank you you know this well III you see
this is this is the bad part of having
you know kids that are that are talented
yeah you're any kind of celebrity it's
harder for those kids to get places
because people go oh just course the
father so-and-so no that's what goes on
I know that we thought of telling you
right now though I've seen it firsthand
I've heard it first saying yeah that
pretty I know these children they really
are super talented kids man well that
kid Dylan I love max your son younger
son Dylan is a sweetheart thank you
right we have to do this thing called
unhelpful advice but this is how we
close up the show
somebody emails me us a problem you
could either help or not help right but
can you listen to the email what about
no questions do you know one all right
so let me answer to the missionary check
out the role built out differently
they're all shaped differently right so
you gotta find what makes them tick
right right so you go missionary there's
no dog in its prison style with us cuz
we have a height discrepancy I'm so
short that I do dog it I can't do it so
she has his lay on her stomach don't
have to like sort of koala bear oh yeah
prison style prison style yeah and on
top like she's on her stomach we're
doing doggy stuff but she's not on her
fours
she's like a dead dog basic I don't have
the height cuz she's tall so I would
have to get end up
alright you told it in this right
ya know what I know that so how high is
the bed this is high it's a low bed it's
a little bad alright but like alright
I'm not looking to beat this listen this
is me doing doggy style but her ass is
here I have to do is stand and do so
tool you stand up let me just say you
next to each other that's great yeah
nothing like a toll chair I know but she
has to get on her stuff I can either do
with that one no but what if she was
bent over on the bed still like stand-in
there you can't do that
what do you don't have its balance for
our sorry I don't have so let's say her
back is to you
right what makes this position exciting
is that it's one of the most alright
she's supposedly a nice girl that's why
you go with yes you know I didn't see
her in the comedy scene you know he's
not a cop she's not a runaround you know
yeah yeah alright so you give a direct
door abacus to you messing around you're
rubbing up against whatever you waking
her up one leg up
what is that'll be like yeah one leg up
so they pick the leg up so you come in
from that angle which is a very lewd
angle if you get and take some selfies
of it you'll see what you'll want to see
that yeah because the nice of the girl
the more exciting one leg up is she's
facing away from me what girl does yeah
there's no good at all
so I say one let me just rehearse it
real quick okay one leg up all right
she'll be like what she's getting woken
up so you cook it more like like like a
drill sergeant Oh says you do it alright
something like so I wake up I'll sneak
in bed right yeah yeah can I be the girl
here alright
but she doesn't oh you just say in the
bed and good morning yeah free start
like like like that just to get a bone
yeah yeah like in the bones you want to
get in the bones yeah very important
very important oh yeah that's half the
battle that's half the battle because
you're going after the purple bacon I
don't want to use dirty words yeah I get
it yeah so you want the purple bacon
yeah yeah get in the bone zone right
yeah yeah yeah one leg up yeah what one
leg up okay there you go there we go now
this is decayed yeah this is the key
yeah they'll always go with the one leg
up because they can't believe they're
doing it themselves right okay so you
got to be ready to invade but a tine
that leg is up you get in there yeah
okay she might start to lower the leg a
little
okay the burns you know too bad you know
what a choke hold is right not around
her neck yeah yeah up around cuz she's a
good sport
yes yeah so you wrap your arm around the
thigh with the one leg ah you know and
you would tack you act as if you know
how horse is something no way no
stirrups no no you got the one leg on
you get the bone in bones oh no yeah
yeah you're in the bone zone but hey you
got the bone in restaurant
we got the rib eye with the bone in yeah
always you'll wind up looking at her
going
bounine bone-in yeah Riya
yeah but now you got your hand free wait
wait let me just let me go through this
I have both arms on her leg knob no one
on shoe once you put the chokehold on
the thigh yeah yeah I'm the chubby
little tie yeah I'm just adding flavor
I know yeah yeah shoot then she should
actually gain a little write that down
gain a little a little more beef or I
can't do the [ __ ] leg thing no you
can do the leg thing you get more of a
bounce if they okay but now you get your
fingers free to work the other part of
whatever's there I don't want to talk
dirty work right you know the the brown
the brown star the brown star like that
what's down there the tank Brown star
and the purple back is to you right
right forget the brown stop you got the
moose lips wrapped around the bone I
know but the thing is is that you're wet
name is so vague like all the stuff now
because the bud is against you right for
the most part she needs to be able to
slap her ass oh okay okay okay now I'm a
snake I know I'm learning yeah you're
already in the yoke you're already in
there if the brown star alone the bronze
stars get enough work to Riley okay the
front aha
alright the front of her yeah the button
whatever you want to call yeah yeah you
weren't done of
with your you bit the hand that's free
yeah because you got the arm around
right so you're doing a whole five
[ __ ] fingers to work with right now
if you can't make her blow you know like
heavy yeah that point yeah I don't think
she should leave you she's a [ __ ]
leave yeah have you ever had a girl have
you ever had a girl that can't do with a
problem yeah that said in her life she's
never been able to uh you know um get I
don't like using that kind of see is
that what you're [ __ ] mean they'll
come yeah house don't tell people that
they already know but I'm saying if you
ever had a girl come to you and say you
know and like it's all electronics to
them yeah no good no good no you got to
break them with a habit will dice get
him in the bone zone yet we've learned
so much from you and I have to say I
could do another three hours but I had
we have to wrap it up